[Musik]
hallo mein Name ist Luca und meine
lieben Freunde ich darf euch heute recht
herzlich willkommen heißen zu einer
neuen Episode Skyblock mit Luca mit wem
auch sonst wir haben für heute
tatsächlich wieder ultra viel auf
unserer To-Do-Liste stehen meine Damen
und Herren und fangen auch direkt an mit
unserem Weg der ja hier vorne noch
weiter rumgehen soll bzw nicht mit dem
Weg sondern mit dieser Absperrung da
können wir einfach mal zack zack hier
vorne weitermachen mit unseren
bruchsteinstufen und während ich das
ganze hier erweitere kann ich euch auch
direkt sagen was wir alles in der
letzten Folge vergessen bzw ja nicht so
ganz auf dem Schirm hatten und zwar
haben wir unfassbar viele challenges
geschafft was mir gar nicht so bewusst
war als ich schlussendlich die Folge
aufgenommen habe ich fange mal direkt an
erste Challenge wir haben in der letzten
Folge 10 Falltüren geschafft für die
monsterfarben da oben da sind ja
insgesamt richtig Falltüren drin also
diese Challenge kommen auf jeden Fall
abhaken was wir auch noch geschafft
haben sind 20 Fackeln
ihr seht ja hier schon einige aber da
oben drauf stehen allein schon mehr als
20 und die letzte Challenge die wir auch
in der letzten Folge geschafft haben ist
die melonenfarben da sind ja der letzte
Folge welche gewachsen natürlich ist das
jetzt nicht so was wie hier perfekt
symmetrisch angeordnet aber es ist eine
melonenfarm ich triggert so ein bisschen
das da vorne kein Gras weg weil das Gras
natürlich hier und da nicht durch kann
aber diese drei challenges haben wir in
der letzten Folge geschafft und wir
werden heute tatsächlich auch direkt
weitermachen mit den challenges zunächst
allerdings werde ich mir erstmal noch
ein wenig Bruchsteine hier rausnehmen
und diese Bruchsteine oben in den Ofen
reinschmeißen haben wir hier noch Kohle
drin ja die haben noch Kohle drin da
schmeißt man ein paar rein denn wir
benötigen natürlich auch noch für hier
vorne drum rum äh so ein bisschen was um
das ganze hier abzugrenzen um den Sony
rum umzuziehen weil wenn ich dann
schluss endlich das möchte ich
eigentlich auch noch heute schaffen da
vorne die Erde geholt habe und dort und
ich glaube ja dahinten genau da haben
wir auch noch Erde dann kommt die hier
komplett hin ach guck mal die fertig
können wir direkt weiter hier anpflanzen
ich habe jetzt gedacht
einfach hier drumherum an damit das hier
so ein bisschen schön ist und ich zudem
auch noch süßbären habe wenn ich die
ganze Erde habe machen wir hier alles
voll mit Erde haben dann einen schönen
Erde Haufen hier mitten in der im
Niemandsland und das sieht alles schön
aus das werden wir auf jeden Fall heute
hoffentlich noch machen das ist aber
auch schon wieder einiges was dann zu
tun ist wir können uns allerdings
erstmal ein paar challenges denn das
Projekt soll ja eigentlich nur bis
Silvester gehen von daher müssen wir ein
bisschen durchziehen erste Challenge 10
Schilder möchte ich machen dafür
benötige ich einfach nur Eichenstämme
und hier einfach so ein bisschen Holz
gehen direkt nach oben ziehen Schilder
werden wir für überhaupt nichts
benötigen wir akzeptieren aber einfach
mal dass das eine Challenge ist von
daher zack ein paar Stecker machen sehen
13 reichen ja dafür und so haben wir auf
jeden Fall zwei drei zack
auch diese Challenge geschafft ich weiß
jetzt nicht genau was ich mit den
Schildern machen soll
schreibt mir gerne in die Kommentare ich
könnte ja hier alles voll mit Schildern
packen und dann vielleicht irgendwie von
euch euren Namen da dran schreiben oder
so also schreibt irgendwas lustiges
oder irgendwas in die Kommentare und
dann packe ich euch vielleicht hier dran
die nächste Challenge die ich allerdings
machen möchte ist erstmal kurz hier die
ganzen Sachen reinpacken wir brauchen äh
Steine haben wir hier wir werden auch
wir haben ja sogar noch Steine da
brauche ich gar nicht so viel
Bruchsteine verbrennen das ist ja auch
unnötig so das sollte auf jeden Fall
schon ausreichen äh ich packe noch ein
paar rein das zumindest die Kohle hier
nicht komplett unverbrauch äh sein Ende
findet er wir müssen tatsächlich zehn
Stein Knöpfe machen von daher zack 8 9
haben wir auch diese Challenge geschafft
packen wir die steinknöpfe auch mal
wieder unten in die Schublade wir
brauchen die zwar eigentlich wirklich
nicht aber ja keine Ahnung besser als
wegschmeißen würde ich mal sagen wir
haben 12 Knochen die werde ich jetzt
einfach mal nehmen und zu Knochen mir
verwandeln um mir erstmal wirklich so
eine Grundausstattung an Essen hier
irgendwie zu machen so dass wir nicht
immer irgendwie rumlaufen und dann
können wir plötzlich nichts mehr essen
sondern haben immer irgendwie äh Brot
mit dabei alles hier wieder schön
anpflanzen ist das Knochen mehr leer ist
wir gehen dann auch gleich mal wieder
zum Monster vom rüber damit ganz viele
von euch in der letzten Folge in die
Kommentare geschrieben das ist übel ist
wenn ich diese Monster schlage und alle
zeitgleich sterben so vom Sound her
keine Ahnung ich bin nicht so nazmr Fan
ich weiß nicht könnt ihr einschlafen
wenn ihr Sounds hört also ich finde so
eine Klimaanlage läuft oder so dann geht
das aber bei allen anderen Sachen ist es
bei mir zumindest ein bisschen schwierig
wir brauchen zudem immer noch Seide weil
ich möchte mir heute am liebsten auch
noch im Bett Mann wir haben schon wieder
viel zu viel vor ich habe irgendwie das
Gefühl dass ich mir die ersten Folgen zu
viel Zeit gelassen habe weil ich dachte
hey komm Minecraft mit Luca wir machen
auf
aber dann ist mir aufgefallen ey wir
müssen irgendwie echt ein bisschen
durchziehen gut die zehn Steinköpfe
haben auf jeden Fall geschafft äh
nächste Sache wir brauchen 20 Zaun Tore
von daher nehme ich jetzt einfach mal
meine Eichenstämme wieder die Stöcker
und das hier um Zaun Tore zu machen die
brauchen wir erst recht für gar nichts
allerdings haben wir ja schon eins
zwei hier unten ist ja auch noch ein
zwei haben das heißt wir müssen
insgesamt nur 18 machen ich glaube man
macht soundhure so in dem man in die
Mitte so macht zack zack zack zack zack
ja okay da kriegt man aber nur die raus
das heißt wir brauchen auf jeden Fall
noch ein paar Stöcker zack zack zack
zack zack wie viel brauchen wir
insgesamt wir haben mit sieben das heißt
wir brauchen noch eins zack zack zack
zack zack und BAM
haben wir auch insgesamt 20 Tore
20 Zauntore also hier die Stöcker rein
Butz Butz Bam Bam und dann haben wir
hier auch noch mal zehn
[Musik]
so insgesamt 18 19 20 damit ihr bescheid
wisst also auch diese Challenge haben
wir geschafft wir machen allerdings
direkt weiter mit der nächsten Challenge
wir müssen heute echt ein bisschen
durchhasseln sorry dass wir heute nicht
so viel bauen aber wir müssen heute mal
ein bisschen produktiv sein unsere
Steine sind hier wir brauchen nämlich
insgesamt 30 Stein Stufen also einfach
alle Steine nehmen hier rein und zack
zack
aber auch die 30 Steinstufen weil sie
Steinstufen hier rein brauchen
eigentlich auch nicht mehr aber gut
meine Damen und Herren wir hassen hier
wirklich heute komplett durch die letzte
Challenge die ich für heute allerdings
auch noch machen möchte bzw was ich
erstmal auf diesen Stein machen möchte
sind Steinziegel in dieser Steinziegel
kommen dann hier vorne ach guck mal
perfekt wie schnell das hier weg ne
Wahnsinn wir dürfen allerdings nicht
gegen laufen oder darf ich auch nicht in
die kleinen darf ich gegen die großen
darf ich doch okay gut ähm wir nehmen
erstmal die Steinziegel packen die hier
vorne hin das ist glaube ich ein ganz
guter Abschluss dann können wir auch
hier vorne den Baum direkt abbauen wir
haben keine Angst mehr die kann ich mir
noch mal eben fix neu machen wir können
doch endlich anfangen zu sprinten und
hier alle so ein bisschen äh schneller
erledigen und müssen
merke ich gerade auch langsam rüber zum
Opfern weil die Sonne schon wieder
runter geht aber quatschig hier in einem
durch aber ich habe noch fast kein
einzigen Cup gesetzt äh wir müssen
nämlich heute auch ein bisschen
durchziehen so die Melonen werde ich
tatsächlich auch noch mal eben kurz zu
Melonen Kern machen so dass ich hier
noch ein paar mehr anpflanze haben wir
sie denn hier ist die Hacke so ich werde
am Wochenende sein so
Tag machen wir hier noch eine hin ihr
dann machen wir hier und dann mache ich
noch mal eben kurz hier vorne bald kommt
noch die cheatfolge wir müssen
allerdings natürlich erstmal noch da
vorne hin
ich weiß immer noch nicht was man damit
machen soll aber schreibt sie gerne
unten in die Kommentare und jetzt hauen
wir uns auch mal direkt hier ein Brot
rein um dann auch die letzte Challenge
mal eben fix machen zu können dafür
brauchen wir nämlich auch wieder Stecker
sogar noch ein paar mehr und Bruchsteine
habe ich am Start wir müssen nämlich
insgesamt zehn Hebel machen so mal kurz
hier so ein paar Dings ich glaube 31
sollten auf jeden Fall ausreichend und
zack nee so rum äh 10 Hebel zack 6789 10
haben wir auch diese Challenge insgesamt
haben wir jetzt heute leute haltet euch
fest ne alle zu Hause nehmen irgendwo
festhalten
wir haben bis heute 8 challenges
geschafft
willst du in jeder Folge weiter geht
kommen wir tatsächlich bis Silvester
durch mit dem Projekt allerdings bewegen
wir uns jetzt beim Sonnenuntergang mal
wieder hier vorne hin zur Monster fahren
hauen die einfach mal fett gegen haben
die ersten getötet die ganzen Zombies
getötet hier noch einer ist jetzt
natürlich nicht so viel hier gespannt
leider weil ich die ganze Zeit da vorne
stand und wenn ihr zu viel drin ist die
sich tatsächlich auch irgendwie
gegenseitig töten weil da kein Platz
mehr ist zack bei den Creeper und so
müssen wir ein bisschen vorsichtig sein
seht ihr schon könnt explodieren ohne
Hexe noch ein Creeper noch mal eine Hexe
die hat irgendwie ein bisschen mehr was
sie aushalten kann zack wir brauchen
wirklich einfach nur Spinnen um
schlussendlich und Wolle zu machen für
Betten kommt da noch was witch Power
Ciao oh der ist direkt gestorben ich
muss auch hier vorne einmal drumherum
bauen dann müssen wir allerdings glaube
ich erstmal Safe zu gehen es sieht schon
sehr sehr schön aus ne
also mittlerweile
es ist ein schönes eine schöne Map Idee
einfach
wundervoll wir haben erst vier Fäden wir
brauchen insgesamt 12 um uns ein Bett
craften zu können ich habe mir
allerdings gerade mal meine Bruchsteine
aus der Kiste genommen um das zeige ich
euch jetzt sofort hier mal eben kurz die
Monsterfarm einmal abzuriegeln aber das
geht gar nicht damit ich brauche
tatsächlich meine Bruchstein damit mich
niemand von denen hier sieht und damit
kein Creeper irgendwie explodiert so
hier vorne zack zack und dann auch noch
mal hier eben an der Seite BAM so dass
da nichts irgendwie in die Luft fliegt
weil wir uns ja jetzt hier vorne ein
bisschen um den Rand kümmern müssen und
hier einfach alles so ein bisschen
einkreisen so dass wir nicht nachher
wenn wir drum rumlaufen irgendwelche
bösen Überraschungen erleben und
irgendwie runterfallen ich habe das
jetzt weiter gemacht ich habe jetzt
leider gerade keine ähm
es geht da ab ich habe jetzt leider
gerade keine fichtenzäune dabei oh guck
mal das ist schon wieder gewachsen diese
süße das geht echt schnell die Sache ist
allerdings dass die glaube ich nicht so
viel Hunger auffüllen oder ich glaube
nur einen halben oder so ja nee einen
sogar tatsächlich aber die halten dann
glaube ich nicht so lange satt so hier
vorne setzen wir noch einen hin zack ich
bau mal wieder ab ich Fackeln immer auch
mit ich brauche tatsächlich ein bisschen
Fichtenholz gerade für die Zäune und
dann verarbeiten als man das ganze
Fichtenholz was wir hier haben zu Zäunen
ich glaube die gingen ja dann so zack
zack da ging das an die Seite und in die
Mitte das 30 Zäune sollten auf jeden
Fall erstmal ausreichen wir brauchen
noch ein bisschen Steinziegel ich habe
aktuell nur 2 Melone ist noch gewachsen
sehr sehr geil ich werde jetzt nicht
noch mehr Melonen Dings der anpflanzen
weil das ja glaube ich erstmal reich mit
den insgesamt sieben Stück hier aber gut
wir laufen mal wieder nach vorne
beziehungsweise Grenzen erstmal kurz
auch das hier eben ab müssen auf jeden
Fall nachher auch noch an einen
Bruchstein Generator um ein paar
Buchstaben abzubauen weil wir noch dahin
heute müssen und da das wird schon
wieder alle stressig aber gut die
zusätzlich ist hier noch was drin oder
phantomhaut und Holzkohle dann können
die Kiste auch direkt mitnehmen und hier
vorne auch den Cut machen Bam Bam habe
ich eine Fackel ja habe ich einen
anderen Hand so nehme ich mal eben ganz
kurz können wir hier auch alles fix eben
ausleuchten ist ein reicht glaube ich
auch mit der Lava aber ich will es
trotzdem immer so ein bisschen clean
haben wir könnten jetzt auch ein
soundtrain machen aber schlussendlich
soll das ja eher alles weg dann in der
Cheat Folge so gut also hier vorne jetzt
mal eben fix die Fichtenholz habe ich
doch nicht gemacht jetzt habe ich nur
jetzt habe ich doch voll weniger ist
dann Schleim
ich setze mal hier drunter eine
bruchsteinstufe und hier so dass wenn
ich hier abbaue ich glaube ich trotzdem
sehr schnell sein muss so aber ich
direkt mal
boah man kriegt so viele Level ne
ey warum habe ich bei Minecraft mit Luca
Staffel 1 nicht sondern Monster Farm
gebaut so ich habe jetzt überall die
Monster fahren mal wieder aufgemacht so
dass dort eigentlich nichts passieren
sollte hier vorne kann ich die beiden
jetzt auch wegnehmen um jetzt einfach
wieder immer nur einmal zu schlagen und
alles zu töten die hier tatsächlich drin
stehen außer die Hexen die haben
irgendwie ein bisschen mehr leben aber
warte wir schauen jetzt mal was für ein
Luth haben also wir haben insgesamt fünf
Seide oh mein Gott
ich kann mir ein richtig geilen Bogen
machen
64 Pfeile einsammeln und Bogen craften
ich meine Bogen haben wir craften müssen
wir jetzt keinen mehr das ist ja quasi
gecraftet die beiden zusammen und 64
Pfeile kriegen wir auch noch heute hin
während dort allerdings mal wieder so
ein bisschen was spawnen ich habe gerade
das meiste getötet werde ich jetzt noch
mal eben kurz äh Fichten anpflanzen und
die mit bohnenmehl direkt wachsen lassen
so dass wir äh direkt bisschen
[Musik]
der wächst direkt
das heißt der steht schon
verschwendet ich lasse jetzt einfach mal
hier vorne noch einen wachsen das geht
weil ein bisschen weiter weg ist das ist
wahrscheinlich wegen dem Fall Türen Dach
da oben aber gut ich baue jetzt noch mal
eben kurz ein paar Fichtenbäume ab so
dass wir jetzt nach diesem Baum auf
jeden Fall genügend Holz haben sollten
um ja 36 fichtenstein Bereichen auf
jeden Fall aus um äh hier alles schön
einzuholen ist ich freue mich irgendwie
mittlerweile weil wir hier gerade schon
so viel zu tun haben dass wir eigentlich
rund um die Uhr irgendwie was machen
können und das hatte ich bisher immer
mal so ein bisschen vermisst bin ich
ganz ehrlich also das hier nach außen
hier in die Mitte und dann hier auch
noch mal nach außen wo wir uns insgesamt
machen wir mal hier das sollte reichen
glaube ich 42 Stück machen das hier
vorne zu schauen jetzt mal die Sonne
geht auf
man ich wollte hier hör doch schon den
Sonnenaufgang angucken
es ist schön das Projekt entwickelt sich
ich no joke ich finde es richtig klar
klar klar Sprachen lernen Babbel ich
meine man kann es natürlich nicht mit
Minecraft mit Luca Staffel 1 vergleichen
das macht natürlich auch niemand von
euch so wirklich weil jeder natürlich
weiß es geht hier um eine Map die wir
spielen das ist quasi eine Challenge aus
Minecraft Forum das ist jetzt hier keine
Welt die ich irgendwie neu generiert
habe oder so aber es ist schon sehr sehr
schönes Projekt finde ich und äh ich
will auch gar nicht so viel quatschen
ich glaube auch wir kriegen es heute
zeitlich nicht mehr hin äh da vorne zu
den anderen Inseln zu gehen weil ich
jetzt schon wieder bei einer halben
Stunde ca bin und äh irgendwie mich
total verquatscht habe weil ich heute
mal die ganzen Challenge schaffen wollte
als ich auf jeden Fall heute noch machen
möchte ist alles ja mal kurz ein Zäunen
deswegen schauen wir mal eben um dich
auf jeden Fall was anderes überlegen ne
da muss ich ja immer drum rumlaufen wie
so ein Idiot aber gut wir haben 42
Steine das ist auf jeden Fall sehr sehr
geil für die Steinziegel zack machen
wenn man insgesamt 40 Stück und schauen
mal eben kurz wo wir die noch alle
hinsetzen können auf jeden Fall hier den
Weg entlang zack zack aber Bam Bam Bam
und dann natürlich auch die schönen
Fichtenholz Zäune drauf BAM die sind
jetzt alle miteinander verbunden hier
eine Fackeln in die Ecke neue Fackeln
müsste ich mir gleich auch mal machen
hier vorne sind noch ein paar Setzlinge
hier müssen wir uns irgendwas überlegen
vielleicht habt ihr eine Idee wenn wir
irgendwann Eisen haben wir noch nicht
gewähren Redstone
wir haben Redstone wahrscheinlich von
der Hexe
ist doch schön
wenn jetzt hier noch alles aus Gras ist
ich bin happy ich laufe jetzt auch noch
mal eben kurz zur Monsterfarm und auch
hier so ein paar tot hier ist allerdings
gar nicht mal so viel gespannt ich hatte
die Hoffnung dass mehr Spinnen ankommen
aber wir haben insgesamt leider erst
sechs Fäden also erst die Hälfte um Bett
zu machen tschüss
[Musik]
oh nein
oh nein da kommen oh nein da kommen oh
nein
wir haben großes Problem mein Schwert
ist vorhin kaputt gegangen ich habe eine
timelapse eingeblendet weil ich
eigentlich diese 64 Pfeile vollenden
wollte ich habe einen der drei haben
noch gefehlt ich habe auch viele Seite
ja habe ich nicht neun habe ich nur
insgesamt aber jetzt kommen die da alle
runter was mache ich denn jetzt
geht's nämlich auch noch ab ey wenn ihr
mich jetzt noch die Lava geschossen
hätten
das mache ich denn jetzt
was mache ich denn jetzt
was mache ich denn jetzt hier hey das
ist eine reinste Creeper Party
hey Leute ich muss tatsächlich an der
Stelle die Folge jetzt auch beenden ich
wollte eigentlich noch das mit den
Pfeilen hier schaffen allerdings kriegen
wir das jetzt leider wirklich nicht mehr
hin da was
[Musik]
also ich frage mich wirklich gerade gar
nichts mehr
ich bin auf eure Hilfe angewiesen bitte
schreibt mir in die Kommentare wie ich
das hier lösen soll mein Vorschlag wäre
von außen irgendwie rum bauen
dann die Monsterfarm irgendwie zu bauen
so dass da nichts mehr runterkommt
aber ich habe keine Ahnung lasst einen
Daumen hoch da wenn es euch gefallen hat
vielleicht hat es euch ja unterhalten
dann abonniert doch meinen Kanal und
klickt auf die Glocke weitere Videos
nichts verpassen
schreibt mir bitte in die Kommentare was
ich machen soll